let's go next to our caller from the
7:04 area code who's calling today from
704 hey Dave yeah that's you who's this
my name is Doron from Charlotte hey
Jordan what's up I just wanted to tell
you I'm a huge fan I want you to all the
time thank you um I just have it I just
had a quick question about merit voting
about sorry mayo mail-in voting yes
merit merit voting voting oh I'm sorry
yes go ahead yeah so I was just thinking
since you know we got Trump of course
that got me thinking that I don't think
that voting is so much of a right it is
a privilege um so in that I would say I
would just like to ask you what the
thoughts of sort of a maybe like
something like a citizenship test but
not the citizenship test but something
just to show that you're knowledgeable
and that you are informed about who and
what you are voting for yeah whether
that be the room listen well right I've
taken versions of this question dozens
of times over the years and I get the
instinct I've taken it also in terms of
parenting like wouldn't we be way better
off if you had to pass some test to be a
parent and wouldn't we be way better off
if you had to pass some basic tests in
order to vote I understand why why that
instinct comes up I really do but it
just can't be done it can't be done
because you first of all I don't believe
that it would be constitutional number
one that that because even though you
consider voting a privilege it is a
right it is a right that people have and
it can only be removed under very narrow
circumstances most of which I actually
disagree with so in practice anything
like that any kind of voting test or
parenting test as others have suggested
it would end up disproportionately
impacting poor people where part of the
problem is they're already lacking
access to education so I it it would
have disastrous unintended or in ten
depending on who you are consequences
and I get the instinct I don't think
you're coming for it from a bad place
like how did 63 million people get
bamboozled into voting for Donald Trump
I get it but it would be very
problematic in its application yeah I
totally agree and I think that's why we
wouldn't need to fix other problems such
as health care education right call it
quits and etc it's tougher right like it
sounds easier to just put in place a
voting test rather than to deal with
those issues but but you you or you're
agreeing that those are the issues that
really we got to deal with yes of course
thank you for your insight appreciate it
appreciate the call thank you so much